Hi, I'm Ankur, the head of
developer education at Amazon.
>> And I am Cezanne and
I'm a course developer at Udacity.
In this course we'll look at different
ways to monetize your game app.
>> We'll show you how to
make money from your game,
which is a subject a lot of
developers leave as an afterthought
rather weaving into the fabric
of the game from the very start.
>> So far you've been learning about
how to program your own mobile game but
it's also important to be able
to share it and make money.
Ankur, what are some examples
of monetization in action?
>> Well,
if you have played any mobile games,
I'm sure you've already
seen a bunch of examples.
It goes into everything from what
a game looks like to ads and
items that you can buy in the game.
>> And remember,
that there's no guidebook to tell
you the perfect ways to monetize.
There are lots of different ways.
After this course, you'll be able to
choose what works best for your game.
Let's take a look at the different
strategies we'll be learning about
in this course.